y at-il aujourd'hui une fracture entre
l'état et le peuple il ya une mignonne
guerre civile qui est évidente et qui ne
dit pas son nom c'est à dire que l'état
fait semblant d'avoir savez ces trois
petits singes là dès maintenant les yeux
les mains dans les oreilles les manoirs
la bouche pas vu pas entendu on ne dit
rien ne se passe rien chacun voit bien
effectivement qu'il y à une centaine
d'endroits en france où la république ne
fait plus la loi et quand vous avez un
ministre de l'intérieur qui vous dit que
après tout l'émotion est plus importante
que la loi alors c'est fini c'est
terminé quand vous êtes un ministre de
l'intérieur qui dit je suis prêt à
mettre à genoux à terre alors qu'il est
déjà ventre à terre qu'il ait déjà
accouché est bien évident que tout est
fini que plus rien n'existe dans dans
cet état français donc on est dans une
dans une situation effectivement de
guerre civile je je crains que que nous
basculions un jour ou le sang va couler
il ya un moment donné une quelqu'un va
tirer dans le tas il va y avoir une
grenade dégoupillée où des rafales de
kalachnikov et alors là plus rien mais
ce ne sera tenable
parce que le chef de l'état n'est pas
crédible parce que l'état a perdu toute
autorité et parce que on crache sur la
police qui fait un métier terriblement
difficile la police elle interpelle
c'est son métier d'interpeller des gens
dangereux agressif violent et armés donc
si on estime qu' il faut faire ce métier
juste avec des avec des petits mots dos
des bisounours ou des petits post it
avec vous non mais vous n'aurez pas ma
haine ça va pas marcher c'est si vous
avez une violence illégale illégitime
il y a dans un état normalement une
violence légale et légitime
c'est le monopole de la violence légale
c'est la définition de max de berre la
police et l'armée sont là pour ça et on
est en train de délégitimer la violence
légale
en dix ans les policiers sont dans la
violence dans l'agressivité sont des
fascistes etc façon qui a maintenant les
autres ils n'ont rien fait alors que la
plupart du temps tout toutes ces
affaires elle concerne des gens qui sont
des voleurs des trafiquants qui n'ont
quasi judiciaire etc